ah
luego de su aprobación por el parlamento
francés el llamado pase sanitario parece
imponerse como una herramienta clave del
ejecutivo para controlar la epidemia de
covite 19
este dispositivo impreso o en su formato
digital permite verificar tres
condiciones si su portador ha sido
completamente vacunado si ha recibido un
resultado negativo a un test pcr durante
las últimas 48 horas o si se ha
recuperado favorablemente de la
enfermedad es imprescindible para
acceder a algunos lugares públicos
congregaciones o transportes de larga
distancia ese dispositivo de control
asegura el regreso a la vida normal
según el gobierno porque reduce
considerablemente el riesgo de contagio
sin embargo ha sido ampliamente
rechazado por manifestantes que se
congregan cada semana para denunciarlo
como un atentado a sus libertades y su
privacidad mientras el consejo
constitucional analiza la legalidad de
ese mecanismo de control las protestas
amenazan con ejercer más presión sobre
los políticos y francia avanza
peligrosamente hacia niveles de contagio
que pudieran volver a poner su sistema
sanitario bajo alta presión
[Música]
ah
para frenar la ola de la variante delta
y acelerar la campaña de vacunación el
gobierno italiano ha decidido imponer el
pase sanitario en una serie de
actividades este pase se obtiene con un
test negativo de coronavirus o un
certificado de vacunación y será exigido
para poder entrar a las piscinas los
centros deportivos en museos cines y
teatros también dentro de los
restaurantes que no tienen terraza la
medida fue recibida con beneplácito por
parte de la comunidad científica pero
también con duras críticas por parte de
representantes de los sectores afectados
miles de personas han salido en los
últimos días a las calles a protestar
además la liga un partido de derecha
miembro de la coalición gubernamental ha
expresado críticas considerando esta
medida excesiva y contraria al derecho
de los ciudadanos a trabajar libremente
a pesar de todo esto el gobierno
italiano se mantiene firme en su
voluntad de aplicar esa medida a partir
del próximo 6
[Música]
quienes se vacunan en australia tienen
un certificado físico y en línea que no
otorga beneficios funciona como un
historial y no como un pase sanitario o
un pasaporte de vacunación el gobierno
federal quiere implementar un sistema
digital único que les permita poco a
poco a las personas vacunadas ir
accediendo a beneficios como por ejemplo
evitar confinamiento es cruzar fronteras
interestatales e incluso salir del país
y volver a ingresar sin necesidad de
hacer cuarentena esto ya es un debate
nacional líderes de derecha advierten
que esto podría generar discriminación y
líderes de izquierda dicen que esto se
podría implementar siempre y cuando sea
la de forma igual en todos los estados
australianos y que sea un sistema
verificable y no falsificables sin
embargo se debe aclarar qué pasaría con
aquellos que por motivos médicos
religiosos o de conciencia no se
pondrían la vacuna el gabinete nacional
entonces deberá decidir la mejor forma
en que australia se va a morir al mundo
pero la vacunación que es lo que permite
hacerlo avanza a paso lento de los 25
millones de habitantes que tiene
australia menos del 15 por ciento han
accedido a las dos dosis de astrazéneca
o fans